hello everyone my heart is like boom
boom boom
so wow this is amazing
I wasn't expecting the cold one with we
bought special suit you know and I for
this special event and we are proud to
be among you guys I want to especially
thank my my precious and lovely team who
supported this film and so Dino DBU
hitch ow Pauline failure and I like how
bad I'm going to be fast
Oscar positi habían McConkey stop sub
the Salome is a team my family mom dad
sister my friends who came the cast
Nicole mercy apartment Bahamas on the
mohammadi family and the district of
loboda net cinema a cinema carries many
tradition one of them is to present a
protest cinema a cinema that highlights
the people against the powerful I hope
that this tradition will continue in
Hollywood and all over the world for
those who dream their work and never
give up everything is possible the proof
I'm here in front of you crazy so let's
hold on all together to our dreams and
ambitions my my action is really bad I'm
sorry and I want to say the biggest
thank you to the Academy and its member
for allowing me and my tiny clue from
Switzerland to share this moment and to
put this to put this film in front of a
mainstream audience so thank you again
to the Academy Awards for this unique
moment to shown the nice Hector and
everyone I met like fantastic upcoming
film directors impart to be among them
and long live to cinema non view cinema
aura thank you very much
[Applause]